it's a different thing you know it's a
different journey i loved testing for it
partly because it's the only time in my
life where i've hit the gym in quite
such an
incredible uh rigorous capacity but it
all worked out the best i think i didn't
have to eat quite so many chickens as
chris hemsworth
every time i looked at him he had
another piece of chicken in his hand
which i didn't envy i have to say that
was just a bit of fun really
i kind of love loki now i feel like i
understand him as misguided as he is i
kind of understand the corner that he's
fighting from
we will accept your most gracious offer
ken branner was so generous with me and
he sort of described when he gave me the
part
what he thought my skills were as an
actor and and that maybe the best fit
for me is is all of the psychological
complexity and we decided that thor was
like a block of granite
you know like a rock and loki was like
the wind kind of dancing around him
that changed so have i ken always said
he wanted loki to have this lean and
hungry look
i was jumping rope 2 000 strikes a day
running five miles down the beach quite
apart from the fact that i i'm really
glad i didn't have to eat so many
chickens
with all your strength
and what good
when i actually saw it realized by the
visual effects
in 3d i sat next to chris hemsworth and
we were
punching each other's legs in excitement
it's it's amazing
what chris has achieved this thor is
absolutely monumental every facet of
that character he's embodied
with um 110 at the beginning he's
arrogant and proud
on earth he's he's funny and tender and
by the end he's
he's humble and and kind of majestic
destroy everything i'm a natural blonde
you can't see it now because i'm
still on my way back from the black i
had to dye my hair and look and
straighten it and all that kind of stuff
and
it's fun you know it's um the thrill of
being an actor is
is getting to live inside the shoes of
of someone who lives a life that isn't
your own
it is fascinating i guess maybe because
i live in britain i find it less
fascinating in some way i think
the grass is always greener you know um
i guess
you know in in america there is no royal
family so the idea that there is one in
britain is more interesting she's a
beautiful girl okay
it's kind of like a fairy tale you know
she's been picked to be a princess
for the rest of her life so i think
there's something quite you know
fascinating
about that she's got her wave down i
noticed she's really good the wrist
action
is really good with the wave like she's
got that sort of queen like she's
obviously been practicing you don't want
to do like the flappy one as well which
is what the kids do
yeah that's not good either i tell you
what prince william has the most
incredibly rigid
extraordinary salute i was so impressed
with his military salute
i actually was packing up all my stuff
to come here
when the wedding was on i think at the
time the moment of the
the actual kiss i was looking for my
toothbrush
and so i missed the kiss but you'll be
relieved to hear that i found my
[Music]
toothbrush
you